from the guy who brought you seven in
the movie about my ex-girlfriend comes a
heartwarming tale of traveling around
the world and killing people David finer
the killer based off the French graphic
novel of the same name is a window into
the Dark World of professional Hitman so
basically like my time playing this
video
game in this video we'll be taking a
deep dive into the movie it's ending and
some of its biggest questions so make
sure to like And subscribe let's get
into it the film is split into six
chapters each one documenting a kill in
the Killer's Journey there's the sexy
lover he inadvertently kills in France
the cab driver and the Dominican the
lawyer and Dolores in New Orleans The
Brute Tilla Swinton the expert and the
metaphorical death of his Hitman past
the story of the killer centers around a
hit gone wrong our protagonist known
simply as the killer although he's been
given a dozen fake aliases throughout
the film misses his Target this was a
hit get financed by multi-billionaire
Clayborn a man will come to know as the
client who hires Hodges the lawyer the
lawyer runs a Hitman side hustle from
his law offices in New Orleans in which
he contracts out Hitman to get the job
done but in this case the job goes to
as a sort of insurance that none of
this comes to bite the client in the ass
the lawyer offers the client to quote
scrub the trail now the client admits he
wasn't sure what was meant by this and
ensures the killer it was nothing
personal and surprisingly the killer
doesn't kill we spend the entire movie
building up to this moment and he lets
the man go but to understand why he made
this decision we must first understand
who the Killer is as a person for
roughly the first 20 minutes of the
movie The only dialogue we hear is an
inner monologue from the killer himself
he is cold both literally and
figuratively as he sits next to a busted
heater he is methodical practicing yoga
and preparing his weapon and and has an
almost existential outlook on life one
is born lives their
life and eventually one dies no doubt
all of this is a defense mechanism to
protect him from the fact he's
committing brutal crimes it's ironic
that he set up shop in a rundown wework
office a company that just filed for
bankruptcy it's a metaphor for his
upcoming failure and the end of his work
contrast this cold depressing and dreary
setting to the film's ending where it's
somewhere warm bright with a positive
outlook on the future with his
girlfriend but this change doesn't
happen at once it's something that chips
away at him throughout his journey a
journey that starts with the botched hit
in France we'll hear him say this quote
of which he lives his life by do what
thou Wilt shall be the whole of the law
it's from the book of law the central
sacred text of Thelma a religious
movement founded in the 1900s by famous
English occultist Alistair Crowley it
basically means that one should seek out
and follow follow their own true path
and this true path for the Killer is one
that sees them change from someone who
shies away from empathy forbid empathy
empathy is weakness to one who Embraces
it I also found it pretty fun that he
talks about the world being a survival
of the fittest while eating McDonald's
now the Killer is deeply methodical
tracking his heart rate preparing for
the job and his inner monologue acting
as a sort of guide on how to kill
without getting emotional or taking
sides I serve no God or country I'm not
here to take sides it's not my place to
formulate any opinion fight only the
battle you're paid to fight music
becomes his distraction with a playlist
comprised of the Smiths a band which
like the killer has many cynical takes
but at the end of the day we'll say
things like I am human and
to the first big crack in the Killer's
worldview is when he travels to his home
in the Dominican Republic to find find
that his girlfriend magdala has been
beaten to the brink of death by two
Hitmen a punishment for his botch job in
Paris it's here we see that the killer
does have empathy a trait he saw as a
weakness because of its vulnerability
and his love for her has definitely made
him vulnerable we'll start to see him
breaking many of his rules and methods
he espoused in the first 20 minutes for
example fight only the battle you're
paid to fight his whole Revenge mission
is paid by no one fueled rather by his
need to protect those he loves than
money or what about forbid empathy
empathy is weakness after Dolores pleads
but promise me you won't leave things
looking the wrong way so he kills her
making it look like she fell down the
stairs and broke her neck instead of a
hit on a woman who helped run a hit
business he also uses empathy while
sparing the client and that might be the
biggest question of all why did the
killer spare the client he's gone
through so many obstacles to get to him
just to leave perhaps it's because the
client knew nothing of magdala remember
that this whole journey started because
of what was done to this girl the killer
will say and you have no idea why I
might be here if we're to believe the
client he basically knew nothing and
paid
$150,000 to just clean up this mess now
if the client did know what was done to
magdala or do anything about her I think
we'd be dealing with a different story
it's also important to note that the
killer does promise to come back and
give the client an excruciating death if
he comes after him what a sweetheart the
Killer's decision to spare the client
could also be impacted by the story the
expert tells him a few days prior it's a
perverted tale of a hunter who goes into
the woods to kill a bear but when the
hunter fails he is offer the choice of
being killed or being sodomized he
chooses sodomy and returns to the woods
again and again each time failing and
each time choosing sodomy the point
being that it wasn't the hunt that was
driving the hunter but something else
you're not really out here for the
hunting are you by the killer choosing
to spare the client he has chosen not to
go on the hunt he is doing the opposite
of what the hunter would have done by
never firing a shot in the first place
there's also the question of what
Fincher and writer Andrew Walker are
saying about the world we live in the
end leaves us with two
multi-millionaires who have committed
terrible crimes both getting away with
it we'll see the killer take wire funds
to a Caribbean bank account with over $8
million in it it's an account made out
to George Jefferson one of his many
aliases in fact almost all of his
aliases are named after characters from
various American sitcoms George
Jefferson and archal bunker from All in
the Family Sam Malone from cheers Lou
Grant from Lou Grant Ruben concate from
The Partridge Family and Oscar Madison
and Felix uner from The Odd Couple just
to name a few at the beginning of the
film The Killer states that a few have
always exploited the many and he counts
himself among those few but at the end
of the film he has put his life behind
to become one of the many well maybe
you're not one of the
few maybe you're just like me one of the
many he has decided to put his past life
behind him and live a life of Peace
we'll see him next to his girlfriend the
one he promised he'd protect and I'm
sure quitting this life of crime is a
part of that promise I swear to you
nothing like this will ever be allowed
to happen again but you'll notice at the
very end there's this Twitch in his eye
a very conscious Choice by fast Bender
here almost as if to say his character
is feeling uneasy or that deep down he
knows he can't leave the hunt forever
it's in his blood the film ends with a
changed killer a man who claimed he was
one of the few now one of the many from
one who shunned empathy to one whose
empathy guided him on his path but does
that excuse all the Terrible Things he's
done in the past not at all it does show
us the capacity for someone to change
and if there's one takeaway from this
film perhaps it's what Fincher said
himself quote My Hope Is that someone
will see this film and get very nervous
about the person behind them in line at
Home Depot it any help getting rid of
that
body but now I turn it over to you what
did you think of the killer I want to
hear your thoughts and theories in the
comments below thanks for watching be
sure to like And subscribe and for more
bad takes you can follow me on Twitter
and Instagram at thinkstory YT until
next time remember Daddy loves you very
much